it fell into my jacket and they pumped
three gallons of red carrot syrup into
my underwear
i was murdered by the ghostface killer i
was supposed to be protecting
sydney prescott but i failed miserably
because at a stoplight the killer
punched through the window
and sliced my neck from ear to ear i
gagged on my own blood dying
i really wanted to die with my eyes open
because i'd always seen that as a little
kid in horror movies and i thought it
was really cool
so i got to do that
that was super fun blood was supposed to
come through my fingertips so
when i brought my hand up i had a little
sponge filled with red carrot syrup that
i was supposed to squeeze and it was
supposed to come through
my fingers but wes wanted to see more
blood
unfortunately my hand was still sticky
from the first take
and the tape that was holding the tube
came undone so
as i brought it up it fell into my
jacket and they pumped
three gallons of red carrot syrup into
my underwear
you know they hinted in the movie that
he may or may not be gay
i think he was i just think it was the
90s so it wasn't
uh that easy to be out at work i'd like
to think that
he'd be living his best life he'd be
promoted to a cushy office job he'd be
married to his
male life partner they'd have a couple
kids and a dog
and they'd watch the drew barrymore show
of course
i really love the chocolate chip cookie
but when those weren't available pretty
much
anything chocolate will do kitkat twix
toblerone always get me through